Molly's game was written and directed by
Aaron Sorkin and stars Jessica Chastain
as Molly bloom an olympic-class skier
who eventually turned to running high
stakes poker games leading to criminal
charges a court case and a book that a
lot of people are read exposing the
underworld of poker with celebrities and
all kinds of really weird this is
based off of a true story and a really
damn good movie Aaron Sorkin's were the
best writers out there a lot of people
know his work from films like the social
network a few good men TV shows like The
West Wing and here he shows himself to
be a very good director he's not quite
as good a director as he has a writer
but that only makes sense because this
is his first time directing this is
certainly a competently directed movie
but it's the performances and the
incredible dialogue and the true life
story that make Molly's game such a
special movie Jessica Chastain I don't
think she can really be awful in a movie
she's been in awful movies but she
herself can't be awful in a movie at
least I haven't seen that happen yet and
she is terrific here this is one of her
best performances it's such a great role
because it's a fascinating character
she's a person who started out as an
olympic-class skier with a serious
spinal condition after an injury she was
forced to rethink her whole life and
somehow ended up hosting these high
stakes poker games it's such a strange
true life story and one that is just
begging to be told on the big screen
this movie is also filled with
oscar-worthy supporting work from idris
elba as an attorney who is interested in
her case and Kevin Costner
as Molly's father he's a very stern
father he tries to train her to be the
best skier but when that doesn't work
out you can tell that he's the type of
father that you would often think is
very disappointed in you even if you do
amazing things and there's an emotional
scene in the film on a bench outside
between father and daughter that I found
to be one of the most satisfying and
touching scenes of the entire year it
really took me by surprise this whole
film is littered with incredible
dialogue sequences most of it is
narrated and sometimes that can be
looked down upon
in writing but Sorkin finds a way to
make it work for this story I think some
of the best films actually feature
narration American Psycho being one of
my favorites if you can pull it off and
if you can make it really work and not
feel like it's just feeding us the
information instead of showing us the
information then it's quite enjoyable
and I think Aaron Sorkin did a good job
with that the movie is quite long at 2
hours and 20 minutes and it doesn't
necessarily drag because I was always
interested but there are sequences in
retrospect looking back on the film that
I don't really feel need to be in the
movie characters and little moments that
are entertaining but don't really add
anything to the story and sometimes it
feels like it's being patted into the
film unnecessarily so that just builds
and builds to a longer runtime which
sometimes can make the pacing of the
film drag a little bit beyond that I was
riveted from beginning to end with
molly's game it has some of the best
performances of the year it has some of
the best writing of the year and it has
a true life story that is so vastly
strange and unbelievable that it truly
has to be witnessed and I think more
people should see it I hope more people
do see this film because it's one of my
favorites of the year I'm gonna give
Molly's game and a so I mentioned in my
last review for all the money in the
world that I had one more review coming
to you guys and it was this one I have
not yet seen phantom thread my screening
for that unfortunately was when I was in
Chicago there's a few more films I need
to see like I Tanya and a few other
smaller films that I haven't got a
chance to see yet here in Cleveland guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I look forward to my best of the Year
video my worst of the Year video and my
most underrated and overlooked of the
Year video coming very soon guys you're
the best thank you so much and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]